en la pista del aeropuerto de Puerto
Sudán estos dos aviones acaban de
aterrizar y llegaron con buenas noticias
las aeronaves provenientes de Qatar y
Egipto traen a bordo toneladas de ayuda
médica y humanitaria para Los afectados
la ONU pidió ayuda humanitaria de
urgencia
hoy 25 millones de personas más de la
mitad de la población en Sudán necesitan
ayuda humanitaria y protección lanzamos
un llamamiento por unos 472 millones de
dólares para responder a las necesidades
de más de un millón de personas Durante
los próximos seis meses
Puerto ciudad es una ciudad de relativa
calma para miles de desplazados en un
país en guerra aquí se multiplican los
campamentos improvisados
no hay Refugio no tenemos familia que
nos acoja y no podemos ir a casa A dónde
podemos ir
no podemos soportar esto más guerra
destrucción no dormimos por los
mosquitos es muy difícil queremos irnos
ayúdennos a llegar a un lugar seguro
después de un mes de combates continúan
los enfrentamientos entre el ejército y
los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido Far mientras en jartum
aumenta el fuego de armas pesadas y
artillería
reunidos en jeda Arabia Saudita las dos
partes ya habían firmado un acuerdo
destinado a hacer respetar las
principales normas humanitarias un pacto
no respetado y cuyas principales
víctimas son los civiles según Naciones
Unidas los combates han desplazado más
de 930.000 personas y casi 200.000
sudaneses se dirigieron a países vecinos
como Egipto Etiopía y especialmente chat